[tense music]
GORDON RAMSAY: I'm
30 feet down using
a diving system I've never
tried before called snuba.
I'm trying to keep my air
hose from strangling me,
praying I don't run
into a great white.
Below the surface, I try to
focus on finding a crayfish.
I fight through the thick kelp.
Underneath it, these
crays are hiding somewhere
in the nooks and crannies.
Limbs on the line, I plunge
my hand into the unknown
of each dark hole.
Damn, these crays
move like lightning.
Finally, I manage to spot
a cray poking his head out
of a crack in the rock.
It fights me with
all of its might,
using its powerful tail
to break from my grasp.
While I've done a little
diving in my life,
I've never quite
experienced anything
as majestic or rewarding
as catching a Tassie cray.
[upbeat music]
Woo-hoo-hoo!
Oh my god.
Yes!
Great job.
Thank you.
Seriously, well done.
Look at the size of that, baby!
That is a beauty.
Man, they move fast.
SHANE: Oh, yeah.
Right.
I can't wait to taste it, mate.
SHANE: Mate, they are the
sweetest thing you ever taste,
guaranteed.
GORDON RAMSAY: Hard work done.
It's time for Shane to make
the most of this beauty
by cooking it two ways.
While the amazing tail
goes into the pot,
Shane serves up some
crayfish sashimi.
Look at it.
A bit of soy in there.
Bit of wasabi.
GORDON RAMSAY: Nice.
Look at that.
The sheen on that is
incredible, isn't it?
SHANE: Yeah.
Bloody hell.
That is [bleep] delicious.
Always tastes a bit better
when you've earned it.
GORDON RAMSAY: Next, Shane
serves it simply steamed.
The money.
This is where it's at.
GORDON RAMSAY: Mate.
Look at that, baby.
Oh my lord.
Look at the weight of that.
I mean, it's enough for
six there, isn't there?
You've done
extremely well today.
GORDON RAMSAY: Look at that.
Wow.
That is delicious.
Do you know what, I'm amazed
at the yield in terms of--
That's the muscle there.
You felt the power
of how much it is,
and now you can see
how it all equates.
GORDON RAMSAY: That crayfish
was translucent, delicious,
meaty, sweet, and super firm.
Incredible.
I'm definitely going
to use it to my feast
at the end of the week.
I'd love you to
come and join us.
I would love to.
You know what goes
really well with this?
A bit of wallaby.
I think you need a bit of
game in there, a bit of meat.
I know a lady that might
be able to help you out.
Serious?
SHANE: Yeah.
Just ask any of the
locals for Sarah.
Sarah.
SHANE: Yep.
Loves a bit of fire.
Yep, she'll be
right up your alley.
The addition of a protein,
the wallaby, would be amazing.
SHANE: Yeah.
That's Tasmanian surf and turf.
That has to be a
centerpiece of my feast.
Do I do it like a surf and turf?
Do I keep it separate?
I got to think about that.
But what I have got
is an amazing start,
because that crayfish is like
the Rolls Royce of the sea.
Best for your travels.
Can't wait to catch
you at the end.